to be like we know each other we're
beautiful I probably not see my friends
oh and you know what guess what I'm
allowed to say okay that I
thought I used to force but I'm not a
Jedi or a Sith
wait say that one more time I need to
comprehend no no because you're gonna do
your mental math and then somehow trick
me with some sort of question I said I'm
my character so my character you didn't
ask but I'm telling you because I'm just
like coming in hot
my character is a very powerful leader
so the footage I have so many questions
the footage looked incredible I loved
the way it looked I'm I'm sure you're
excited to see that footage by the way
the footage is incredible I'm really
actually very disappointed that I have
to wait till like September or some time
of next year I know I know me too and
they're like 2024 I'm like guys you're
kidding me I want to know what happens
yeah so I'm curious what has actually
what has surprised you about the making
of the series that you didn't expect
going in you know I didn't I I love how
many like that it was led by women you
know um Leslie's over there another one
of our producers
are there any more rain was in here as
well and
it felt really cool to be led by women
women of color queer women I was like
in this world which is very like you
know white male oh I've seen I've seen
the convention it's a lot of white guys
I'll say it and that was really exciting
you know especially because like I mean
Leslie is like a fanatic okay she is
like she is our encyclopedia for all
this and so it's it's also lovely to see
like
it's lovely to see like the different
kinds of fans and like they're making it
and the way that she like had like the
creative control of this thing like in a
Chokehold it was inspiring what is it
actually like being on set I don't know
if you were weren't but when there's all
these Jedi with lightsabers and they're
all together and you know filming scenes
like that because as a fan that's just
cool I mean cool to see them I'm like
okay so really my first experience of
being like Oh my God I'm in Star Wars it
was actually when I went to go and visit
they were filming something something
that was actually in that little clip
are you saying all the all the Jedi
lined up here no not that
it was it was actually I got to see some
of Carrie Anne's work that she did with
amandler and I was just like first of
all as soon as you walk onto the set
you're just like I'm in Star Wars you
know like this is Star Wars even though
it's like a new place that you haven't
seen yet it's still just like so
specifically I mean you just you're like
I'm in it
and that was really cool and it was
really cool I wish that I I wish that I
you know I'd gone to do some stuff okay
well you never know Season Two my last
thing for you uh I love learning about
what is what was your reaction to the
scripts and like the tone of the show
and what do you think is going to really
excite fans when they see it
you know when I read the scripts I mean
that is really kind of what brought me
into it and the tone and knowing what
the tone was going to be because I was
working getting to work with one of my
favorite directors in the whole world as
he said I could say this uh even though
I'm technically not supposed to say this
but I've already said it coconutter
um and obviously like he's just such a
talented filmmaker and so I was like
this in your hands
I'm so in like
say no more you know and I think that
the fans are going to have that same
sort of reaction I think you know Leslie
was very considered about the filmmakers
that she chose to help her make this you
know and then I mean this woman she's
just like she's she is a force she is
the first okay and so it's just like her
mind her ideas her love for this and and
her resilience like getting it done and
at the end of the day I mean look this
is the corporation we're talking about
so it's like a lot of times ideas can
get a little bit like closed down and
and not and not let you know their wings
spread and Leslie made sure that the
creative wings were flapping
from start to finish and I think people
are gonna love it on that note I'm just
going to say I really sincerely can't
wait to see it and as always you look
great thank you thank you so good to see
you